speaking of trials by the way
we have this impeachment trial this week
i'm going to be flying actually to dc
to participate in this not not to
participate i'm not going to be uh
you know presenting any evidence or
voting or anything like that but we will
be there we're gonna be covering it with
verdict
uh which you'll recall my podcast with
senator cruz actually began last year
during the last impeachment trial but
now
a year later it's deja vu all over again
groundhog day again
and they're impeaching trump except
maybe they're not
maybe they're not because there was an
impeachment vote in the house goes to a
trial but trump's no longer president
so is it an impeachment trial or is it
not republicans have been arguing this
is unconstitutional
doesn't meet the constitutional
standards for impeachment
so far democrats have kept a unified
front but democratic senator chris
murphy
on one of the sunday shows on chris
wallace's show actually
had to admit that maybe this trial is
not constitutionally legit
i think we have a constitutional
responsibility to hold this trial
and i think you laid this out for
senator paul there is clear precedent
for the
senate moving forward on an impeachment
trial once being sent articles
even after an official has left office
and so you know my analysis here sort of
begins and ends with what is my
constitutional responsibility i don't
think our job ends just because the
president has left office in part
because
impeachment comes not only with the
provision to remove an official from
office but to disqualify them for
future office so there's still a
consequence to
president trump if convicted okay so
chris murphy gets all the democrat
talking points out at the top right yes
we have a responsibility to hold the
trial the house impeached we have a
responsibility we have to do it
the the the impeachment provision of the
constitution uh includes not just
removing a president from office but
also
preventing him from running for office
in the future you can tell how confident
democrats are that trump is unpopular
that they are desperately after he's out
of office trying to
prevent him from running again probably
because they think that no one would
vote for him right
yeah is that why not so sure about that
what he's saying here by the way is
hotly debated and i just don't think
it's true
what the impeachment provision of the
constitution says is
you will remove and prevent from running
for office in the future but you can't
remove him from office so if you can't
remove him from office
you're not fulfilling the impeachment
provision so it's not legit so you can't
prevent him from running for office
in the future the senate can't just
start taking votes and saying hey yeah
we don't like the cut of johnny's jib he
can never run for president
there are very specific criteria that
need to be followed here so after chris
murphy gets out his kind of bogus
argument and all the democratic talking
points
he's pressed further and further and
further and he does have to admit
maybe maybe this isn't quite so
constitutional as we've been pretending
it is
i will admit that this is of course a
matter of first impression
uh and so i don't think the case that
senator paul is making here is a
ridiculous one
i come to a different judgment i think
that that clause that gives congress the
responsibility
to deny an official future office
requires us to take this step even
though the president has
left office listen to those caveats he
says the case that rand paul is making
which is the case that all of us
conservatives have been making which is
that this is not a constitutional
impeachment trial
yeah okay it's not ridiculous and then
the other caveat right at the top he
goes well look this is
this is just a matter of first
impression first impression chris we've
been talking about this for weeks and
weeks and months and months
and you impeach the guy last year
probably presumably you've thought about
the question of impeachment before why
would you say this a matter of first
impression
because you know that the argument
you're making is bogus
and you want to give yourself a little
bit of an out fair enough i mean i'm
glad you're at least
admitting that much it's more than most
democrats will do lindsey graham i think
described very well what this
impeachment is uh
really going to amount to which is that
it's a farce it's a partisan exercise
and it ain't going nowhere well it's not
a crime i mean
the house is impeaching him under the
theory that his speech
created a riot when you look at the
facts many people had already planned
to attack the capital before he ever
spoke well the trial memorandum
the trial memorandum from the house
impeachment managers actually lays out a
pattern of behavior they say it wasn't
just the speech they say this was
cultivated over time
yeah well here's what i would say that
if you believe he committed a crime
he can be prosecuted like any other
citizen
impeachment is a political process we've
never impeached a president once they're
out of office
i think this is a very bad idea uh 45
plus republicans are going to vote early
on that is unconstitutional
it's not a question of how the trial
ends
it's a question of when it ends
republicans are going to view this as an
unconstitutional
and the only question is will they call
witnesses how long does the trial take
but the outcome is really not in doubt
okay i broadly agree with lindsey graham
here he actually kind of undercut his
own argument a little bit though
and maybe he was just speaking loosely i
could i could see some ways in
some different ways to interpret that
but at the beginning right he says
what trump did is not a crime now
this is an answer to the question look
trump incited an insurrection therefore
you know you've got to impeach him right
and what lindsey graham says is no
no i lindsey graham has said i think
trump acted rashly i don't think he
should have
he was irresponsible in his language he
shouldn't have said what he said
but you can criticize the president for
the things he said between the election
and january 6th
and still conclude as i think you have
to conclude
he didn't commit any crime what crime
did he commit
first of all he didn't incite an
insurrection he said before during and
after the riot
don't be violent be peaceful much more
than you can say about democrats during
the blm riots
but what crime did he commit
so when lindsey graham at the end of
that says look impeachment's a political
process
well yes and no it's a political process
but it does have
a legal aspect too namely you need to
commit a high crime or misdemeanor
and then the political process takes
over from there
i don't even know what crime they could
accuse trump of committing
he didn't commit a crime that's the
legal aspect
then you move on to the political
question there's no way politically the
guy is going to get convicted
unless something dramatically changes
some new shocking evidence comes out
between now and and the end of the
impeachment trial quote-unquote
impeachment trial
you've already got 45 senators on the
record saying they're not going to vote
to convict
so it's just a force
so much for unity and healing why are
they why are they going forward with
this
because all we can talk about is trump
one the democrats are genuinely afraid
of trump
two the establishment needs to have
trump they love trump they need trump to
kick around they need trump
as this embodiment of evil that they can
they can go after
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there